bom dia
eu sou o bruno então vim começar com uma
fala minha pergunta
na verdade a onde que tu tava no oge do
ano passado
sei que alguns vão saber ao certo há
muito já não ter a menor idéia
eu no oge do ano passado eu tinha
acabado de realizar um sonho
eu tinha transformado ciclo numa espiral
não precisem vai pegar papel e caneta
porque não é uma aula de desenho
quando eu falo ciclo eu falo daquele
caminho pré determinado que a gente tem
aquela esteira
eu por exemplo eu entrei no colégio e já
se esperava que passasse no vestibular
então tinha uma pressão já por boas
notas não pega recuperação aí passei no
vestibular já tem a pressão por pegar um
bom estágio na administração do estádio
tem que ser uma grande empresa e aí foi
lá consegue um bom estágio depois um
outro estádio como a chance de
efetivação e assim por diante
aí me formei e já se esperava que
tivesse um emprego e já começa a pressão
por casar por ter filhos tem um bom
carro e uma boa casa enfim vocês devem
saber qual é o próximo passo da vida de
vocês e vocês podem também não acredito
que o próximo passo nem necessariamente
alguma coisa que goste que queira mas
ele já está no automático
entendo também que você estava pensando
nossa oitava do bruno tem pressão para
ter um bom carro mas agora então
imaginem um ciclo completamente
diferente do meu
diferente de vocês o ciclo por exemplo
as crianças que moram lá na comunidade
de chapéu do sol na zona rural de porto
alegre
essas crianças estão num contexto onde
não teve planejamento familiar o que se
espera se delas não o que se espera
delas não é que elas têm um bom carro
mas sim que elas sobrevivam
quando elas entram no colégio apresenta
para ajudar em casa
então o próximo passo delas pode se
achar um emprego o emprego ou o próximo
passo pode ser a menina engravidou aos
15 anos
o próximo passo é a pressão ainda maior
pelo retorno financeiro
o mundo das drogas e da violência
esse ciclo mais chocante e aí tem uma
saída para esse ciclo
sim ea sair da educação só a educação é
capaz de quebrar o ciclo da educação é
capaz de transformar cabe abrir a cabeça
e aí eu ano passado depois que eu
descobri isso eu quis ir mais a fundo
mas aí eu descobri que a educação também
está num ciclo
esse ciclo ele começa comigo
começa contigo quando a gente vai para
as ruas reclama tá insatisfeito com a
educação atual e à ips bom quem é o
responsável por isso é que é o culpado
da educação está funcionando na hora me
veio o governo
e aí eu entrei numa escola completamente
diferente da escola que eu estudei e aí
de um lado houve uma televisão lcd
parada
de outro uma lousa digital dentro da
caixa que os professores não sabemos a
bom governo está fazendo alguma coisa
então quem é o culpado disso na hora
pensei os professores os professores que
são acomodados desmotivados não querem
fazer a diferença mas quando entrei na
sala de aula professores com brilho no
olho com vontade de transmitir o
conhecimento deles para aquelas crianças
às professoras também estavam num
contexto que o aluno muitas vezes
tratava ele com violência não tava nem
aí pra aula dele
bom quem é que o culpado então disso o
aluno
as crianças não querem aprender mas aí
eu vi crianças sedentas por aprendizado
por conhecimento
as crianças também a educação não era a
primeira opção primeira opção era ter o
que comer
e aí quem é o culpado
eu pensei bom estamos pais dessas
crianças é a comunidade onde essa
criança está inserida
e aí quando eu fui conhecer um pouco
mais da comunidade os pais
encontrei uma mãe obesa alcoólatra e
analfabeta
essa é a culpada educação está dando
certo
essa pessoa que não teve oportunidade e
aí eu vi que o culpado sou eu o culpado
é a sociedade que todos os outros
eles estão fazendo alguma coisa e eu
estou reclamando
e aí a gente tem um ciclo da educação
onde vai procurando um culpado e
colocando a culpa em alguém reclamando
mas se esse ciclo fosse uma espiral e se
a criança aprender esse conteúdo na
prática a criança numa aula de gráfico
ela fosse lá fizesse uma pesquisa
tabular os dados analisar esses dados e
se o professor participasse de tudo isso
o professor pegasse aquele sonho que ele
deixou dentro da gaveta executasse
tivesse pessoas que auxiliassem
estimulassem ele e se a escola fosse
mais do que aquelas cadeiras
enfileiradas e o quadro negro no fundo
fosse um espaço diferente estimulasse o
aprendizado conhecimento e seus pais
participassem disso os pais aprendessem
junto com os filhos os pais vissem a
escola não só eu mas como esse espaço de
aprendizado mas também um espaço de
oportunidade de geração de renda da
comunidade vice à escola
ponto de referência à resolução de
problemas
o governo disse tudo isso pudesse
participar de todos esses momentos e se
tu não fizesse parte da mudança do que
não aguenta mais e assaltado por um
bilhetinho tu que achou um absurdo uma
menina de 15 anos está grávida
tu tá de saco cheio de explicar dez
vezes a mesma coisa eo funcionário não
entende que pode mas até porque só poder
é para os americanos precisa precisa
fazer parte da mudança que precisa mudar
a educação
eu ano passado tava num ciclo 1º ciclo e
eu conheci uma pessoa de um ciclo
completamente diferente do meu
e nós juntos quebramos o ciclo da
educação
sim eu consegui ano passado no meio das
manifestações
eu queria mais do que levantar cartazes
a reclamar eu queria ir lá e fazer a
diferença
e aí a gente criou escola complexo é uma
escola colaborativa formada por pessoas
uma escola que acontece dentro da escola
pública no contraturno
nessa escola se aprende empreendendo se
aprende os conteúdos curriculares se
aprende se comunicar e raciocínio lógico
resolvendo problemas e desenvolvendo
negócios aqui na imagem que que vocês
estão vendo é o cristian
numa das reuniões da empresa do negócio
da conversa aqui o cristian teve
oportunidade de presidir essa reunião e
ele está se comunicando pra adultos
jovens mais velhos e crianças mais novas
do que ele
afinal não é pra isso que a gente estuda
13 anos de português para se comunicar
e a gente começou a conversa com eles
com os alunos identificando quais eram
os conteúdos que eles estavam aprendendo
identificando quais eram os problemas
que a gente conseguir resolver com isso
problemas tanto na escola como da
comunidade os negócios em potenciais e
aí no momento que foi acontecendo a
gente vão desenvolvendo os professores
os professores de um espaço para criar e
aí
à medida que isso foi crescendo esses
negócios precisavam ser assumidos e
vieram os pais que assumiram os negócios
e aí começou a gerar renda para eles e
eles ofereciam esses produtos e serviços
a uma comunidade carente ea ideia é que
o governo venha junto também participe
desse processo
aí a gente tem uma espiral de educação
algo que não é pontual é contínuo e
acaba envolvendo cada vez mais pessoas
algo que começa com a gislaine de 11
anos ea coordenadora de recursos humanos
negócio da conversa
a islândia tem que elaborar os contratos
e para isso ela pede a ajuda da
professora raquel que dá aulas de
português para ela lamenta a professora
raquel junto com ela então elabora
trabalha questões de ortografia
pontuação esse contrato é feito pra mãe
de gisele estava desempregada mas ela
faz os salgadinhos deliciosas e
salgadinhos
eles são vendidos o pai de luan que pra
fazer a festa de aniversário dele ele
tem que pegar dois ônibus para chegar no
mercado ea idéia é essa que a gente
comece com algo micro vá para algum
macro que a gente melhore não só os
índices de educação mas também de renda
per capta de empregabilidade ea gente
tem o ciclo o espiral que acaba
envolvendo cada vez mais pessoas
mas para isso acontecer nós precisamos
de pessoas
pessoas como tu como tu pessoas como a
manilha que é contadora nada a ver com a
educação e que fazer diferente
pessoas como a priscila em marketing mas
não estava satisfeita com o mundo que
ela vivia pessoas como alice que
estudantes de medicina e queria fazer
sua parte
pessoas como tu sim mesmo porque as
pessoas elas clamam por mudanças mas
elas são a mudança o futuro da educação
depende de ti e aí teclado que vai ficar
do ciclo onde a gente reclama e tenta
procurar culpados ou na espiral onde a
gente faz e acaba envolvendo mais gente
aonde que tu vai estar no oge do ano que
vem
muito obrigado